mais en france on est plutôt en retard
sur des problèmes qu'ont éducation
sexuelle alors quand on a trois filles
quatre filles comment ça se passe
ben sont des sujets qu'on aborde très
simplement à table à l'occasion de pas
mal d'exemples
ouais franchement parce que j'y ai mis
le feu au départ on les attendait pas
comme ça mais maintenant il me semble
que c'est possible d'aborder ces sujets
là en toute simplicité et les plus
jeunes en bénéficient sans qu'on ait
pour ça peut choquer leurs oreilles pour
leur apprendre des choses qui ne sont
pas de marge mais vous même les parents
n'avaient pas reçu d'éducation sexuelle
non absolument pas alors on s'habitue
vite pour en annoncer quand même quelque
chose de la trade and education
c'est vous qui l'avez fait disons qu'ils
nous ont appris le strict minimum
puisque moi dans la rue reste qu'est ce
que vous apprenez vos parents le naturel
et le la suppression des tabous il me
semble vous entendez par là suppression
des tabous et bien
tout ce qu'on peut se raconter en classe
quand on emploie notre petit vocabulaire
que serait une façon de s'exprimer en
classe qui d'ailleurs se limite parfois
rien que un petit groupe en classe j'ai
eu des exemples en visitant un château
un exemple très drôle qui ne l'a fait
tout rires et puis le gardien des
châteaux demandaient ce qui arrivait
parce que que cela faisait partie de
votre vocabulaire il avait envoyé un
moulin il avait employé le terme casimir
qui pour nous ce n'est pas une chose
très spécial pour lui ces petits tissu
alors ça nous a fait rire
il a cru que c'était un anneau petit ami
ça veut dire fait que ça veut dire que
vivre mais prenons le cas va rendre la
pilule est ce que qu'est ce que vous
dites à vos enfants vos filles pour ça
nous on est contre jusqu'à une certaine
limite contre de journaux fieg est à
dire qu'à mon avis la pilule devrait
être donnée que les femmes déjà mariés
depuis un certain nombre d'années ayant
déjà un certain nombre d'enfants ou
alors vraiment un cas
spécial de maladie ou vous donner me de
la femme quoi qu'ils ne pourraient pas
avoir d'enfant mais à une jeune fille ça
devrait être complètement interdit à
roanne on peut pas parce que vous êtes
vous
les convictions pendables l'emploi de la
pilule pour une jeune fille c'est
inadmissible
mais il peut arriver un accident à ce
que vous avez une fille qu'à 20 ans
est-ce que vous avez envisagé de lui
faire prendre la pilule n'ont jusqu'à
présent non non c'est moi qui leur ai
proposé un accident arrivé rien
n'arrivera pas puisque n'ayant pas la
paix où je ne ferai pas de bêtises et où
cause de vous peut pas profiter des
choses de la vie
mais se souvient voit là bas parce que
tout simplement en toi tu considère pas
ça comme un plaisir mais comme une voix
[Rires]
s'est décrochée peut vous à vue pour
avoir si l'enfant je pense quand même là
l'éducation qu'on a reçue c'est un peu
ça quand même tu montes oui bonsoir dans
un bout d'essai en amoureux
[Musique]
pourquoi avez vous eu six enfants
allez on est si sa fin premièrement
d'eloïse quand on s'est mariés non non
non non on en a voulu honorer folle et
on voulait six enfants
on s'est marié au bout des six enfants
au départ oui après au premier bain la
fin on était quand même un petit peu
découragé par ce que fait d'être
difficile ça a été très difficile oui à
tout point de vue santé aussi bien pour
les enfants que pour les mères on est un
peu dégoûté quam enfin les six enfants
qu'on voulait avant de nous marier on
les a eus
étant marié à lorient une fille je
voulais absolument voir un garçon donc
c'est pour ça que notre employée lors le
troisième aussi et après l'heure on peut
dire peu ne s'est pas des accidents mais
un peu méthodologie nouvelle
méthodologie nous et qui dans le fond
c'est quand même une méthode de
contraception du bon qui nous permettait
de limiter enfin d'espacé du moins les
naissances varie bien qu'elle était
assez rapprochées quand même mais est ce
que vous avez eu d'enfant tout de suite
après le mariage
non non c'est marion février 51 nôtres
et neymar est né en juin 52 mais on n'a
rien fait pour l'instant va avoir au
contraire on était plus isolée au départ
ah oui on a pleuré pour en avoir et
après on a pleuré parce qu'on allait
trop est ce que vous pensez avoir
suffisamment profiter de votre vie de
couple je ne coupe tous les deux sur ma
part comment sûrement pas puisque mes
moyens matériels étaient aussi très
limité au départ ou dans la cas 3 tout
de suite
donc on ne connaît pas on ne connaît pas
de vie
2 on a tout de suite eu deux enfants on
a eu un troisième enfant
on a eu tout de suite une vie de foyer
une vie de famille nombreuse presque
tout de suite ce qui fait que nous y a 2
vraiment à 2 et puis le départ de notre
mariage était difficile aussi puisque
moi je faisais kipré ce moment-là de 5
euros une heure maintenant de travail en
commun et friis de couture donc elle
elle rentrait le soir vers 6h 6h30
il fallait qu'on se couche très tôt
puisque je me devais 3h30 4h pour partir
au travail donc le début du mariage
était pas pénible puisque danser mais
bien mais au point de vue matériel
c'était quand même assez dur et cette
intimité du couple est ce que vos petits
enfants vous empêche pas aussi de la
voir maintenant si c'est forcément on
dispose de très peu de temps pour penser
à nous deux parce que vous le regrettez
enfin oui oui parce que on est nous pas
il ya une période de notre existence
qu'on a été noyé par les besoins
matériels parler les exigences des
enfants et et on se retrouve à près de
50 ans sans avoir eu le temps de penser
à nous vous pensez que maintenant que
les enfants sont plus grand vous allez
pouvoir vivre aussi pour vous mais je me
demande si ça n'arrive pas trop tard et
si vous vous voyez que vous étiez jeunes
mariés et que vous réfléchissez à tout
ce qui s'est passé depuis
quel est le bilan qu'on pouvait faire
parce que c'est comme ça vous pensiez
que créer une famille certainement pas
non je pense que c'est un visage qu'on
se rend compte de la valeur des choses
mais l'ensemble est positif pour nous
certainement oui pour nous et bien sûr
enfin regretté pas vos six enfants
assure ma part ça les pendus sur
évidemment
les moments de d'échec ou de difficulté
évidemment on se dit si on en avait
moins auraient peut-être moins de souci
non on les regrette pas
sûrement pas et pour le pays est ce que
vous pensez que il a besoin des familles
nombreuses
je ne sais pas s'il peut dire que ces
familles nombreuses mais je pense que
nous ça n'a jamais été notre objet non
non j'ai jamais voulu repeupler la
france dans ses achats serment non
[Musique]